okay
[Music]
luke dominate here at the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today we're doing
the longest road trip in the united
states
you guys ready for this yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys we're here in key west
florida and we've rented a car with
unlimited mileage and uh we're gonna be
leaving here and spending the next six
weeks driving 7
500 miles north all the way up to dead
horse alaska and in case you're
wondering where my wife and my youngest
child are they're going to be joining us
along the way they're off having fun
with in-laws right now it's going to be
a crazy adventure and we'll be doing
lots of stuff along the way we're going
to be floating rivers we're going to be
noodling catfish
you guys excited yeah
our flight into miami landed at 5 a.m
and we drove straight from there to key
west and i haven't slept in about 48
hours so we're barely on our feet but uh
we're determined to make the most of it
is my first time in key west so we're
gonna go out and get some breakfast and
uh see a few sights before we start
trekking north
[Music]
this look good
all right let's do it
you want to try this
[Music]
all right now we got some food in this
maybe we can stay awake
well now that we got breakfast out of
the way we're gonna go check out the mel
fisher maritime museum real quick
check out this banyan tree guys
look at the size of this thing these
banyan trees are so cool
no that right there those are silver
coins this is the gold they found in a
sunken ship there's golden balls golden
coins they found these in the bottom of
the ocean
see these are hammers and tools yeah i
said one of the cannons from the atocho
yeah yeah they shoot those
one it's a pirate with a head
was that cool do you like that yeah you
ready to go get a hotel
yeah let's go get a hotel i'm
terrible one tired we go
we got some chinese food
great david eat while tommy's in the
bathroom
all right let's go check out the beach
and pool
oh you guys are getting older we can do
this more
[Music]
hey tommy i think it's time to call it
sun setting have you had a fun day yeah
it's been fun
well it is a beautiful morning and the
boys have been asleep for 13 hours i
think it's time to wake him up
i think we were all a lot more tired
than we realized
all right before we head off we are
going to organize the car we need to get
an organization system where this next
month is going to be
very very messy this is like our
everyday stuff that we need when we go
into the hotel plus my camera equipment
we've got usb splitters and chargers
everywhere
and over here you can see we got these
little organizers hanging on the back of
the chair we'll see how that works we
got a long way
our next destination is crystal river
florida that's 404 miles or 7 hours 3
minutes
[Music]
we're kind of ripping right through the
keys and through florida there's so much
cool stuff to see in florida but we've
been here many many times so we're kind
of anxious to go see stuff that we
haven't seen before
all right we're gonna get some fresh
fruit here
all right we got breakfast
who wants some star fruit
oh look at that one of my favorite
fruits see star fruit
i love dragon fruit i used to eat this
every morning in hong kong oh it's the
pink one that stains i think i was
hoping to do the white one
don't drop it don't drop it
i already sucked on my fingers all right
good for you oh these are the best
bananas in the world
hey guys you want to drive through the
everglades and see some alligators yes
all right let's do it
florida everglades are so cool we love
coming down here we just finished a
video where we spent two weeks hunting
pythons and iguanas and fishing for
invasive fish here in the florida
everglades if you want to see that video
i'll put a link down in the video
description below
we are seeing tons of alligators
see him he's right there steve right
there
well we're in florida so we got to get
dinner at sunny's barbecue
amazing
hey guys guess what
we just drove our first 500 miles
now we just need to do that 15 more
times
welcome to crystal river florida so far
we've traveled 540 miles and i've got to
get these guys ready for bed because
we're getting up at 6 a.m to go shark
fishing
i am so sick
look at that look at the size of that
thing
well we got a little bit of a problem
it's late neither one of the boys are
asleep tommy is feeling pretty under the
weather and nathan's got a little bit of
a runny nose
anyway so i had to call the shark
fishing guide and cancel and uh we're
just going to kind of see how they feel
in the morning and figure out what we're
going to do well it was definitely a
rough night last night tommy woke up
with body aches coughs and chills and
the whole works he's looks like he's
either got flu or coven
so we're gonna do some testing and try
to find out what it is and in the
meantime we need to be isolated and so
we're kind of canceling everything we
were planning to do here at crystal
river we were originally going to go
shark fishing this morning and then do
some fun activities this afternoon
so instead what i figure we'll do is
we'll just try to get all of our driving
out of the way and uh that way we can
isolate and kind of get something done
and we should get the test results back
by this uh afternoon around 6 pm or so
all right we got some medicine and tommy
and he's starting to feel a little
better we're gonna head northwest
towards panama city beach florida which
is about 266 miles or about five hours
away
all right guys welcome to panama city
beach florida so far we've driven
826.6 miles
holy mackerel that is massive that is a
pulled pork with a fried onion on it and
uh i've got a alligator sausage po boy
well good news we got the test results
back and tommy's negative for covid so
just good old-fashioned cold and flu
so uh that makes life a whole lot easier
here
and uh i think we just take it easy
tonight and tomorrow and uh we should be
good all right guys got a belly full of
barbecue i think it's time to go get a
hotel it's getting late
well i need to get these guys to bed and
i've got a lot of editing to do on my
computer so i will see you guys in the
morning well good morning it's a
wonderfully lazy sunday morning and the
boys are feeling a lot better but i'm
going to give them one more day of just
hanging out and doing nothing just to
make sure we get them over this cold and
don't spread any germs around doing a
little hotel laundry here
all right there we go got some laundry
done well i just got off the phone with
black creek outfitters and canoe rentals
in southern mississippi and the black
creek is completely flooded we were
gonna do a two-day
camping float trip in southern
mississippi tomorrow and uh that's not
happening so
we are off to a rough start with with
our plans
but uh i'm gonna sit here and uh try to
see about our plan b's
we're about an hour away from the
alabama florida border and we're gonna
cruise right on through to mississippi
and hopefully we're gonna be able to do
some pretty cool stuff in mississippi by
the way i've got a gopro mounted up here
doing a time lapse video so this entire
trip all the way from key west to dead
horse alaska i'm gonna do a time lapse
so that you guys can watch the whole
drive and of course i'll put a link to
that video in the video description
below
look tommy there's a big snapping turtle
in the road
like little teeth marks and mud marks on
top of the gopro
all right guys we just got into alabama
[Music]
the government street hey tom tom you
want to go see a battleship yeah
all right let's go see a battleship
we're here in mobile alabama and we
drive by and we see a big battleship
museum for the uss alabama and tommy is
obsessed with military stuff so we are
totally getting tickets hey look at
sherman tate we've got to drive one of
those you want to go on the battleship
yeah
it's one of those random things we just
saw on the highway we just got to pull
over and do this is way
there's where they patched up holes see
they shoot that out of that
i thought
look at that 40 millimeter cannon see
yeah you go you just stare right through
there and that's how you aim it
you see oh yeah there's a couple right
right there next to it
oh man they don't make these ships for
six foot four people that's where they
keep the bullets they have to have a
machine that loads it because the
bullets are too heavy to pick up oh i'm
so hitting my head on stuff
this is the hospital
hey you guys want to go see the
submarine
watch out dad's dad's got to get through
see this is the steering wheel for the
captain and that's the steering wheel
for his kids so they can feel like
they're participating
push the wrong button you're in trouble
huh
oh my goodness that is a good hike
there's there's the kitchen
all right hop up there bud oh don't kill
my back oh son of a gun oh that was cool
we got a long way to go we're gonna get
back on the road
check it out there's mardi gras beads
all over the trees and power lines see
look at the necklaces all up in the
power lines
all right guys we just drove 1000 miles
all right guys we stopped to get gas and
i'm gonna go ahead and make some lunch
here
all right got some white castle sliders
and a couple corn dogs here
oh that was hot by the time we get to
our next spot should be all cooked
welcome to mississippi guys
[Music]
oh yeah those are toasty here
you like hamburgers cooked on the engine
all right should we go see some
alligators yeah
all right you hold that that's gator
food right there
you want to go feed gators it says
unattended kids will be sold as gator
bait
look at this boys look at this
we got a gator nugget here let's see
let's let me try it here
oh geez apparently that's how you do it
oh
well let's go check out the baby gators
yeah you guys have held gators that size
i caught an alligator about this size on
a rod and reel once and tommy wrestled
it
there's one right there
i thought there's one oh he's a lot
bigger than i thought
[Music]
barely dodged the rainstorm
we were supposed to be doing a two-day
float of black creek here in southern
mississippi but all this rain and a
tropical storm flooded everything out
the rivers are super swollen
look at those railroad tracks in the
water
you want to try chicharrones
they're fried pork skins
david here try it
it's funky
but it's really good
you're right
funky but good
i've lost seven in a row
[Music]
oh my last banana
is the best bananas i've ever had in my
life
all right guys we've done
1247 miles and we're here in mcgee
mississippi so tonight i'm going to try
to find a plan
c
and see if we can't go camping somewhere
here in mississippi tomorrow night
nathan died
all right guys we're here in chunky
mississippi and we are going to float
the chunky river how much sunscreen do
you guys got oh
not enough that's how much you got it
looks like you got hit by a flock of
seagulls
all right
oh you guys you guys want to sign your
name yeah so you got to sign the chunky
mobile put it on the seat tom yeah this
is cool i like your ride
thank you very much gentlemen
we'll see you tomorrow morning
so we're gonna spend the days kayaking
and swimming and fishing and uh we're
gonna camp tonight on the river and just
see what happens are you doing it
jump out jump out and swim if you want
you can wash it out
i'm peeing right now
you're peeing right now i think right
now
now careful don't fill up the kayak full
of water
[Music]
oh oh ramming speed
oh no
paddle finds up hey look at that tree
let's go over there and jump off that
tree go for it
hey guys i'm starting to feel some rain
i think we got a little bit of a storm
coming in
oh no attacking your brother
get out of the sweeper tom
paddle for the bridge
there we go
all right well we'll just hang out onto
this bridge till this rain storm passes
and from the looks of it it won't take
very long
the bridge is peeing on you
all right guys should we keep going
yep
there's a lot of yellow water in the
bottom of this kayak nathan ah it's
raining again
the storm deceived us
uh oh we got a ramp tommy
we'll take a little shelter here and see
if that storm blows over again oh oh oh
hold on
yeah put that in there there's your
backpack hold on tom you're just gonna
flip yourself again
climb on the
there you go
our down sleeping bags and dry clothes
were in that bag we're gonna find out if
that's waterproof or not the rain's
eased up a little bit so we're gonna go
try to get a campsite because i do not
want to set up the tent in the rain and
it looks like we're going to have on and
off showers for a little bit
do you want to switch nathan
hey
this beach over here to the left
actually looks like one of the best
spots we've seen so far
thanks boy
got two hooks on here one for catfish
and uh one for like bluegill and stuff
we'll see if we can catch anything
[Music]
oh there's some good thunder over there
all right who wants to watch godzilla
movies
all right we got godzilla versus
mechagodzilla too
yeah you guys said you want to beef stew
we just finished dinner and the storm's
blowing over so we got a little bit of
time to relax before sunset something
was pulling a little bit of drag i think
we just might have some junk on the line
but tom's gonna reel it in and check it
out
what you got what you got
oh what a gorgeous fish well
congratulations tom that's what your
first mississippi fish i think yeah
what'd you catch nate
oh you got oh yeah
right there a little baby tadpole
there he goes
oh those are all your tadpoles yeah okay
look at that one he's big i'm trying to
swim in my hands well here we better get
him back in the water you've got some
serious bug bites back there
those are doozies
[Music]
let's get ready to roast some
marshmallows
you got some stick
one strawberry
one vanilla
give that a go
all right guys it's officially sunset
and their bedtime
you guys having a good day
awesome well let's get you guys tucked
in it's getting late okay got a busy day
tomorrow well good morning it's another
beautiful day here in mississippi and we
got the sun coming over the horizon all
right guys who wants some blueberry
granola
well we've got about four miles to go
before we get to our takeout spot and
the river is moving at a pretty good
clip so we should get there in uh short
order
nathan you look like a pro oh
[Music]
here we go
oh i hit that i felt that on my butt
[Music]
there's the bridge we're getting near
the end
listen if you guys are near chunky
mississippi and you want to float the
chunky river make sure to check out
chunky river kayak canoe rentals i'll
put a link down in the video description
below
say goodbye to chunky mississippi
[Music]
now you guys might notice that we're not
driving a lot of interstates on this
trip i selected the avoid highways
option on my gps so we're going to drive
back country roads
all the way to alaska
as the last prayer drifted toward the
train
welcome to alabama boys
this is the only state we're going to
visit twice on this trip
all right guys we've traveled 1550 miles
and we're at dismal canyon alabama here
we're gonna do some camping
all right
my goodness
look at this
[Music]
and we're here at dismal canyon alabama
and we have reserved what is arguably
the coolest campsite in the entire state
not only do we have this grotto and
waterfall all to ourselves but it's also
home to
a really rare globe worm that lives only
here and hopefully tonight we're going
to get to see some
[Music]
no
is that refreshing
yeah look at this
all right let's get set up
hi i'm going to pick you
got the ted set up we got to get the
fire going we have some lovely food for
dinner tonight we're in alabama
so tonight we're gonna have steak and
asparagus for dinner and tomorrow
morning we're having scotched eggs
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hey tom
look what we guess what we have for
dessert
[Music]
there we go five scotch eggs all hot and
toasty ready for tomorrow
we can just heat them up in the morning
and they're ready to go absolutely
delicious all right guys the sun's
starting to set and we are going to go
on a little tour of dismal's canyon and
try to see the dismalites the little
rare glow-in-the-dark bugs that uh live
here so we're gonna go meet up with our
tour guide here and uh it's gonna be fun
oh you got a firefly
wait oh
butt would glow
let's go find some dismalates
[Music]
this is the first scorpion i've ever
seen in the wild oh he's he's totally ah
i touched him
check it out it's a poisonous centipede
if you shine a uv light on them they
glow in the dark
oh yeah
well that was really cool but my camera
couldn't pick up 99 of it we saw dozens
and dozens of dismalites we saw
glow-in-the-dark funguses and uv light
glowing centipedes and the grottoes down
there are really amazing we only got an
inkling of some of the cool rock
formations that are down there uh but uh
we're gonna go check them out tomorrow
morning in the daytime because i think
that is gonna be one cool hike but it's
late and uh we're gonna head back to our
campsite
it's late let's get to bed
hey dad
there we go scotch eggs
tommy do you like scotch eggs
oh i love this you really want to get
crazy with them you can put hollandaise
sauce on them
they are delicious
so uh we're gonna kind of clean up camp
get the car all packed up and uh then
we're gonna go and do a hike
while i'm packing up the camp the boys
are climbing up on the waterfall and
catching crawfish and just having a ball
oh you guys are way out there
this is one of the coolest campsites
i've ever been but uh let's go do some
hiking ready to explore this canyon yeah
all right let's do it so this hike we're
doing right now is the same hike we went
on last night only this time we get to
see the scenery
hey guys wait
look at this
[Music]
cool
[Music]
all right nathan you ready to go to
arkansas
no
all right let's go do arkansas
all right we're driving to northwest
arkansas and it's going to be about
seven to nine hours and tomorrow is a
little bit of a mystery the water levels
i've been a little skewampus in arkansas
so my plans to float a river are a bit
up in the air
[Music]
hey guys look it's the mississippi river
welcome to arkansas boys
i'd rather have a sleepover with a
free-filled rabbit carcass
oh
we've driven a total of 2 000 miles and
now we're here in harrison arkansas in
the northwest of arkansas
and i am going to get to take a shower
ah
morning we had a wonderful night's sleep
we got showers done did some laundry so
we smell a lot better the weather's
pretty miserable and i'm not sure if or
when it's going to let up so we're just
going to kind of drive down to ozark
national forest and stop and check stuff
out along the way
you know we just saw a billboard for
something called mystic caverns and so
going in a cave sounds like a good idea
not exactly what we planned but it's
gonna be dry and we're excited about
that
[Music]
[Music]
tall
[Music]
yeah that was a nice thing to do to get
out of bad weather
well check it out guys this is the
buffalo river and one of the most scenic
rivers and best float trips in the
united states we wanted to float this
but the river is way down
i drive
all right guys check it out it's an old
farm
well we're driving through and i saw
this sign for the parker hickman
historic farm
isn't this crazy
let's turn the
turn on our lights
yeah i see it
oh guys look i see the chimney
that's cool
that's where they put all the naughty
children
that was cool you guys want to keep
driving yeah
poor nathan he was in the middle of
saying this is the best day ever when he
bit it and just totally hurt his arm and
leg it didn't help that me and tommy
started laughing
did you just fart on me
look at this
this [ __ ] bridge made by nature it's
a natural bridge and then they wouldn't
put handrails on it
so you can kind of get an idea of what
it looks like right there
[Music]
dangerous things can happen that was fun
but for tommy the highlight of the day
is listening to our audiobook which is
entitled i am a genius of unspeakable
evil and i want to be your class
president wait do you like the book oh i
love it you can't have a good road trip
without a good road trip book
oh snake
who's telling a loud nerd story to a
loud nerd friend
oh that was sketchy
[Applause]
there we go guys it's the car wash
waterfall in the ozark national forest
car really needs it by the way i'm glad
we came
[Applause]
so he just turns purple and starts
coughing
oh this would be perfect this is like
the perfect swimming hole do you want to
go swimming yeah
look at this
all you think shy
job one two three
oh my butt hurts oh that was a bad idea
[Music]
here here come with me
oh i really hurt my butt and my foot and
my elbow my
back i can't even
buy them
we're getting the boys dried off and i
think we're gonna go do some camping
here it's just a great campsite and
there's nobody here you guys up for some
camping
all right
oh
[Applause]
you want to put waste on your meat yeah
that warms your belly up
oh yeah grab your marshmallow sticks
you
oh
let's send it and put it like that
well this turned out to be our plan c
but not too bad i'm really pleased with
how this day turned out
oh good
and our fur has been used to make paint
brushes and toothbrushes
do you guys sleep well this has been an
awesome campground we've had the whole
place to ourselves on a friday night
right next to a gorgeous waterfall and
swimming hole
so we're leaving arkansas ozark national
forest and heading northwest to go find
a hotel somewhere around the border
between missouri and arkansas
[Music]
what are you guys in the mood for
japanese food
all right we'll go get some japanese
food you know i've eaten a lot of sushi
at a lot of japanese food but never in
arkansas let's give it a go
i like to shoot you like the sushi
mochi ice cream all right let's go find
a hotel
i need a shower and i've got a lot of
video editing to do but we're gonna be
here for two days and we're gonna try to
see a few things oh poop
wanna see four and a half thousand
dollars of garbage that's what it looks
like right there
i better find myself a new high
performance laptop in the next few days
or there won't be any videos for august
so
well it is a beautiful sunday morning
and uh i do a little ironing
but uh we're gonna head off to church
and it's just gonna be a real low-key
sunday today well guys do you have a
good time at church yes well i ran into
a friend from alaska that i went to high
school with and uh at church and so uh
we're gonna go over and meet his family
and hang out with his family for uh
the afternoon so that's gonna be kind of
fun
well thank you very much for having us
let us come and destroy your house a
little bit thanks for coming by we'll
see you well we've had a wonderfully
relaxing low-key sunday but it's time to
go hit the sack i'm gonna see you guys
bright and early in the morning we're
going camping tomorrow you ready yeah
all right let's do it
who wants frosted flakes
well we've drove 2 200 miles so far but
today we have a meager 26 mile john to
missouri where we're gonna do some uh
camping and fishing it's gonna be a good
time
we're in missouri now
okay
all right guys we're here at the
creekside campground near joplin
missouri and uh we're gonna be spending
the day here and it is absolutely
gorgeous
that looks like fun
this is just a great little whirlpool
oh boy here we go
walking on broken flint
watch out gate oh we lost nathan
broken toy car and there's a yeah
that's a big rock it's a rock tire
that was pretty awesome
[Music]
okay what do you catch
oh look at that behemoth
whoa
you're the legs on that one
boys just found a four-wheeler and they
abandoned me in a heartbeat
it is so nice and quiet here we have our
pick of spots so i think we're gonna go
all the way down there on the end we'll
have all the privacy we want and the
boys can chase crawdads and tadpoles
while ice get the car cleaned out and
the tent set up
boys are down to the last marshmallows
so they're gonna try to roast moon pies
moon pie on a stick this this could be
the best thing we've ever done in our
lives okay we're losing chocolate
what do you think would you do it again
you like that thomas nathan it's raining
we better go
just got the kids to bed and sitting out
here by the fire i think i see some
bullfrogs
you got a bullfrog incredible frog
there goes
oh he's quite the jumper
well good morning everyone sleep well
yeah
oh
there we go beauty
oh my goodness isn't that the most
beautiful fish you've ever seen
if you guys are ever in missouri you
want to come to the creekside campground
i'll put a link down in the video
description below well guys we've had a
wonderful time but we've got to keep
moving we got to get to oklahoma
so we've driven 2
355 miles so far on this trip and we're
gonna head towards oklahoma city and do
another 252 miles
welcome to oklahoma boys
well we got a lot done today i took a
shower we got some laundry done we've
eaten dinner and we're just relaxing
because tomorrow we're getting up early
and we're going noodling for catfish
there you go pancake machine that's
awesome
all right guys i'm meeting here with
nate with adrenaline rush noodling and
uh we're gonna go out and wrestle some
catfish right that's the plan
now for those of you who have no clue
what noodling is basically you find a
catfish in a little den under water and
you go and you stick your hand in in the
den and you grab them by the lower jaw
or you get them to bite you or whatever
and you wrestle them out
and here in the summer time the catfish
are spawning and the females will lay
the eggs and then the males guard him so
you go in there and you try to find a
spot where catfish has made a nest you
feel into all these little holes trying
to see if we can't find one on there and
wrestle them out there's not gonna be
anything in the holes
but a catfish or an empty hole the
beavers and the snakes and the turtles
they don't really live in these holes
you got one back in there
i felt one in here but i'm trying to
locate his other ways to escape i'm
trying to block up his back door
well i believe he must have came out the
back side will
uh it doesn't
banged
very silty in here
i'm gonna noodle a spider
okay oh he got away
hey don nate you guys having fun
oh yeah look at that little leopard frog
look at that
yeah everywhere
oh yeah that is a big boy oh no that's a
monster yeah big flathead well we saw
one big dead catfish and two pretty
good-sized catfish skulls so definitely
some monsters in here but the water's
really low so i think that kind of
kind of killed it for us today
we only have a little bit of time left
but we're going to try one more spot
[Applause]
so we're just kind of bobbing down with
the current
going to long jam to log jam looking for
catfish nests
look at that noodle the turtle
you want me to jam my leg in there as
far as i can yeah maybe put both of them
in there and just go as far as you can
yeah i got as far as i could
didn't feel anything
empty so there's a big empty log about
this big around it just goes back that
way and i stuck my leg in as far as i
could and he went down in it as far as
he could
couldn't feel anything but it looks just
super fishy there's these undercuts in
little caves here along this rock
so we're just kind of working our way
down did you find the edge over there
one just swam over my foot really yeah
okay
heads up boys don't step on a snake they
got rattlesnakes here
[Music]
well me i'm sorry didn't work out but we
had a ball yeah we tried didn't we i'm
gonna give you a reason to come back and
try again awesome well guys did you have
fun even though we didn't catch any fish
oh yeah it was fun we are now at
and seventy 2573
miles into our journey and we're gonna
drive another 171 miles to the great
salt basin in northwest oklahoma we're
gonna do some camping meet up with some
friends and we're gonna dig for some
crystals
he was obviously incarcerated for a
your
reason
is on the right
all right we're here at the great salt
plains in northwest oklahoma and i have
a couple fellow youtubers here going to
be joining us for a little camping and
fishing we've got the walker farm fam
here with that great channel here in
arms family homestead definitely check
out their youtube channels we'll put
links down in the video description
below but i think we should go fishing
shouldn't we yeah we found a great
spillway
holy mack i could see the carp
are you reeling him in or is he reeling
you in
there you go you got him in the net you
try to lift it like a normal net
it'll snap well we fished for about an
hour i watched a lot of other people
reel in fish we're gonna set up camp and
get some food
well i've been setting up the tent the
boys have been playing and swimming in
the water apparently this lake is super
shallow you could walk across the entire
thing this is the goat sausage yep
these are from your goats right
they got a hard skin on them right out
of the middle
you guys want to eat the mre yeah all
right come on let's do it
this is army gatorade what do you think
of the army gatorade it's pretty good
not bad
and then we put that heater in here like
this
that is hot okay
now for the main course you ready okay
so here's your pork patty
and you got your maple syrup here give
that a shot see what you like
date one before
what do you guys think of the mre you
like it that's really good we gotta grab
some jalapeno cashews there
how hard is
it right guys i stayed up way too late
just jaw-jacking with everybody and
having a great time but the boys should
be in bed so i'm gonna go put them down
and i'll see you guys in the morning we
are going crystal digging and doing all
sorts of fun stuff
okay well we're over here with our
dehydrated meals here
that's the waffle maker thing there's
survival and then there's living this
this is squarely in the latter category
you need a plate for it
no
it's been just so fun just to hang out
and chat with with nice people and the
boys are having a ball they're playing
in a mulberry tree over there i'm just
going to kind of do the slow pack up
i've got to reorganize the car a little
bit and then we're going to go out and
dig for crystals out in the salt plains
so we got a little caravan driving
around to the other side of the lake to
go dig crystals the arms family the
walker family coming with us
this is the oklahoma great salt basin
and we're gonna dig for selenite
crystals
we just finished listening to the book
holes on audiobook in the car so the
boys are convinced that this is camp
green lake all right you want that one
look at this
it's a big chunk of salt
there's actually really good salt
in the world
[Music]
so the material here is this fine brown
silty sand and then you get these
pockets of this coarser like beach sand
material and then you look inside it and
then there'll be pockets of crystals
like look at this this is all crystals
right here
oh look at that sucker you can see a
little bit of an hourglass in there
can't you
christmas there we go
look at that look at the hourglass shape
inside
hey these kids have been digging up huge
crystals they're scraping that's how
you'll find them
yeah that one that one is look at how
look at how perfectly formed that one is
[Music]
that is pretty
oh that's a big one
oh this one's
this one's uh
that is a serious specimen right there
look at that that is gorgeous
yeah that is awesome
all right guys we gotta get head north
to kansas but we have had such a great
time
make sure to check out the walker farm
fam youtube channel and the arm family
homestead youtube channel i'll put links
down in the video description below guys
we've had such a ball thanks thanks for
coming thank you everybody hop on in all
right guys so we're gonna drive 247
miles north to castle rock kansas and
we're going to get to drive through
dodge city so that's going to be kind of
cool so far we're at
2750 miles on our journey dead shortly
after david
hey boys welcome to kansas
[Music]
all right welcome to dodge city a town
that was once called the wickedest
little town in america
all right guys we're here in dodge city
and that's the boot hill museum
according to the sign next week's the
testicle festival wow we just barely
missed it
these are war hammers
it's a coat made from a buffalo
it's a pair of scissors yeah it's a
little folding knife this is a list of
all the different brands
all right we bought a little souvenir
for my youngest boy jacob
all right guys you want to get some ice
cream you got that
all right we got some fajitas for the
road we're in good shape now all right
guys that was fun but it's time to get
out of dodge
all right little chrysler pacifica you
can do this
look at those cliffs
welcome to the badlands of kansas and uh
we're gonna call it home for tonight
[Music]
well now that we've got the tent set up
we're gonna try to explore these rock
formations a little bit
this reminds me of something i'd find in
southern utah not western kansas all
right we got bellies full of food we're
gonna go to bed it is late we'll see you
guys in the morning oh that's pretty
good morning well today is gonna be a
simple day we've got about four and a
half hours of driving to do to get to
nebraska we're gonna be camping on a
beach on a reservoir
and other than that we you know we
really don't have that much to do oh can
you hear that
it's a pack of coyotes over there
all right guys we're leaving the kansas
badlands and heading to mcconaughey
reservoir in northwest nebraska about
miles
hey guys we forgot to brush your teeth
we're driving down the street and we saw
a sign for the fake fossil museums well
i think so
that's pretty cool see look we got the
selenite crystals from oklahoma
look at that is that cool
no i think it's a little yellow
oh
check out the the fossils
nathan you make a good annie
oakley no this is the old prairie house
see it's made out of mud see that's the
dried cow food to make the fire go
that's a 10 10 gauge shotgun that's a
big old beast oh my goodness look at
that thing oh yeah that's a fossilized
fish that looks like a giant tarpon
prehistoric turtle seizure oh yeah yeah
yeah it's a mosasaurus
that was pretty cool
thomas gowdy
you guys want to go to that playground
yeah
we're driving through colby kansas we
saw this enormous playground this
thing's huge
girl there's 11 slides here
it's nice to stop and look at things
along the way
[Music]
welcome to nebraska
[Applause]
[Music]
we're now in the same time zone as mama
holy mackerel this reservoir is crowded
okay we're here at mcconaughey reservoir
here in northwest nebraska and it is
crazy crowded
i was led to believe that when you
reserved a spot you got a spot
look at this
as far as the eye can see
the entire shoreline is solid rv's
intense
you know i went online to reserve a
campsite and it said okay this is beach
area 14 do you want a reserve beach area
14 i clicked yes
yeah i don't think i got a reservation
and i was kind of lame you know you
spend 30 dollars on reservations and i'd
get more privacy camping at a nascar
event
yeah the temperature's 100 degrees
fahrenheit outside
i think is another good reason to find
another place in canada
wait a minute that's the plaid river i
had to cross that on the oregon trail
video game okay we're driving down the
road trying to look for a campground and
i looked at my window and i saw a
chimney rock you know from the oregon
trail and there's a campground
that's not cold
here we go we got a camping spot we got
the tent set up
and look at that there's chimney rock
yeah we're just right on the oregon
trail aren't we it's hot do you guys
want to go into town and go do something
to kill a little time yeah
so i got a little idea to beat the heat
the boys have never been bowling
yeah this looks perfect
get up to the line but don't go over it
yeah you got some
oh that was a good throw
[Applause]
so we're just here in bridgeport
nebraska doing some bowling and having a
good old time at the place to ourselves
very social distance friendly
daddy got a strike
oh
look at this nathan's kicking our butts
someone just turned the party switch on
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
yeah that's how you do it did you have
fun are you glad we were bullied
holy crap look how many scooters are
trying to get
well guys we've traveled 3 400 miles so
far on this trip but we're leaving
chimney rock nebraska and we're headed
for denver colorado where we're gonna
meet becca and jacob at the airport and
be able to continue the rest of this
journey as a whole family which i am so
excited about
all right we're stopping in scott's
bluff nebraska and we're gonna go to the
bluffs bakery get some breakfast
blueberry bagel bites
that's good
all right i got a big fat order of
biscuits and gravy here
oh
they're beautiful i think they asked how
many counting down the minutes till we
get to see mommy and jacob
hey guys look we're actually going up a
hill
i think we're getting close to colorado
hey guys welcome to colorado
whoa
the next left then your destination will
be on the left here we gotta get some
flowers for mama anything is that good
for mama
thank you for the flowers that's really
cool
all right guys we're leaving the denver
airport and we've traveled 3 600 miles
so far and we're headed 122 miles west
to leadville colorado where we've rented
a house
ah the kids are getting fed they're
watching cartoons
they're making a mess of the floor we're
settling in nicely well guys we've had a
little bit of a rough morning at 5am
jacob crawled into bed with me and becca
and then threw up all over us and uh
then the other two boys followed suit
about an hour later uh so it's been a
lot of barfing and everyone's just kind
of
laying
down uh my best guess is it's altitude
sickness leadville here where we're at
is at 10 000 feet
why do you think you're sick and we're
not is we were up
sleeping upstairs
and everybody else was sweeping
downstairs today we were planning on
hiking up
a mountain and camping at 11 000 feet my
sister and her family were going to come
and join us on the camp out and uh so we
got to call them and
kind of think about a plan b well tommy
and jacob have perked up a bit
but nathan's taking a turn
hang in there bud
so we're gonna
just pack up and get out of here as
quickly as we can
well guys i have never seen a car this
full
but it's okay because they were going to
spend two weeks in it
so we head down the mountain
yeah
we've already descended about 2 000 feet
and the boys are doing a lot better you
guys feeling better
[Music]
you want to go play with cousins yeah
all right let's do it hey how you doing
oh good to see you hey
all right guys it's a hot summer day so
what better to do than have a picnic
with the family so i bought way too much
food we're going to do just that
if i can't go camping at the top of the
rockies with my boys then i'm going to
eat good food
we put mayonnaise on it have you handed
it
and there we go
mexican style corn
cole here has never eaten an avocado
before we have this nice salted avocado
here
we have a belly full of delicious food
and uh we've got a whole bunch of water
balloons down there and the kids are
chomping at the bit to start hurting
each other
let me look at everybody you're back oh
my goodness
are you having fun
yeah go get them nathan look at here
come here you've got a nipple welt oh my
goodness that one's kind of turning
purple in the middle half the kids are
covered in welts the other half are in
timeout that was a good successful water
fight well it's getting late and the
boys are gonna go and camp in the
backyard tonight with their cousins so
they're pretty jazzed about that the
best part of this is kendall is setting
up all the stuff my back is screaming
right now the idea of pulling out all my
luggage to get to my camping gear sounds
horrible well good morning guys we're
here in denver with my sister's family
and it's just been lovely we're going to
do about an hour long drive in the car
and then stop for lunch
so i'm going to heat up some of our
lunch on the engine block
yeah hop in and get yourself buckled bud
okay we're headed to georgetown lake
about an hour from southern denver where
we're at
all right becky you ready for some lunch
brother-in-law's got some fishing rods
out the kids are gonna do some fishing
me and beggar just gonna sit here and
relax
all right high five cool
there we go it looks great monster trout
just enjoyed herself but uh now we're
gonna go and do a little scenic train
ride
you guys are enjoy the ride
all right we're at the phoenix gold mine
just a little bit away from georgetown
and uh we're gonna do a mine tour and do
a little gold paintings
tommy uh
this is where that water came up and
filled that crack
of a turn hit it turn it to turn you
twist it you can move it up and down
where they got farther around
big piece of pyrite right here
so you've got copper iron you're going
to have gold in there
didn't you just tell me the gold is real
heavy you have a bunch of black sand in
the bottom see all that sparkly stuff
because once the gold gets the bedrock
it can't sink it we've learned the
principles we've studied the technique
now we go down the creek and do it for
realsies all right guys i'm going to
pretend to be pioneer polly here for a
little bit let's see if we can find any
gold
i don't know if you can see it this gold
is so tiny but there's little teeny tiny
specks right in there you getting rich
you got some black sand in there yeah
oh is that a flavor emily's hiding in
the woods to avoid anyone finding your
gold there's some bling in there every
pan had a little bit oh look at that so
becca is the gold panning queen she's
found at least one flake in every pan
i found diddly squat ah she's always
been a good sugar mama did you guys have
fun at the mine
yes
here's the unedited truth of family
vacations jacob's screaming at me
because i buckled him into his car seat
instead of letting him do it nathan's
mad because he didn't find any gold
tommy's happy and mom's happy and i
threw my back out so he just poops her
pants that'd be a you know pretty
typical day
well we're gonna end the day with the
bang we're gonna have a babysitter come
over watch all the boys feed them full
of pizza
and all the adults are going out
good times
well we had a lovely evening but it's
time to get some kids to bed i'll see
you guys in the morning
ah good morning guys and welcome to our
last day here in denver my sister's
making waffles the boys are watching too
much tv and hanging out with cousins
we're having a great time
but we've got a lot of driving to do
today
[Music]
glad we did that rather than camping on
a mountain yeah yeah we have traveled 4
100 miles so far we're now going
364 miles west to vernal utah
all right guys here we are hoosiers pass
at the continental divide if you spill
water on this side it'll drain into the
atlantic ocean the gulf of mexico you
spill water on this side goes down to
the pacific ocean
we're officially across the peak of the
rockies
covered the whole seat with
we're here in steamboat springs and
we've been in the car for four hours so
we're going to stretch your legs a
little bit
[Music]
there you go that'll keep you nice and
cool keep the sun off what
is that what you want buddy
there you go
it's a lucky 13 13 beef patties 13
slices of cheese two buns one pound of
fries if you finish it in 30 minutes
it's free
but you die
oh oh my gosh
everything on this menu sounds so good
for all the wrong reasons oh this is
deep fried mac and cheese
that's really good
this is tommy's hamburger the bun is a
powdered donut the la freak pineapple
pepper jack jalapeno sweet chili sauce
and peanut butter jalapenos and peanut
butter dang it that's actually really
good
what do you think babe is it good i'm
trying tommy's it's really good
it's really good if you want to eat here
it's the back door grill in steamboat
springs colorado steamboat strings is
fun
well we got into the hotel a bit later
than we expected so i got to put this
down and get kids to bed and i'll see
you guys in the morning
we're here in vernal utah which is home
of dinosaur national park we are gonna
go see some dinosaurs you guys excited
yeah
all right we're here at the utah side of
the dinosaur national park
so right up there in the canyon is one
of the richest dinosaur fossil quarries
in the world and a lot of species like
stegosaurus were discovered up in there
those are dinosaurs those aren't like
recreations or sculptures of them like
you see in the museums these are real
dinosaur ones and look at how many
hundreds of them there are
look that's an amazing fossil look how
well well put together that is
[Music]
all right guys we're gonna drive into
the national park a little bit there's a
lot of really cool canyons and
petroglyphs well we're going to go take
a peek at the petroglyphs the kids
wanted to stay in the car
well here's some petroglyphs of the
fremont people
that's pretty cool i like the ones at
the top best where you can still see
some of the red coloring in it
all right guys we've driven 4 400 miles
and we're gonna drive another 130 miles
north to fort bridger wyoming
we're driving down the road and all of a
sudden there's these signs pointing out
where you can get fossils
look at this it's a crystal
oh look at this tommy beautiful
oh look at this look at this
this is fish scales they got fossilized
fish scales right here look at that a
whole bunch of them
that's a big fish scale right there
pretty cool but we still got a lot of
driving to do we better get going here's
the crystals oh that's super cool we're
on highway 191 going north from vernal
and there's all these signs along the
road telling you which cuts contain what
fossils and from which periods and you
can just stop your car along the road
and collect fossils
we're arriving dinosaurs hunted i'll
pull over all right guys there might be
raptor bones here
this looks a little bit like a piece of
fossilized wood or fossilized bone or
something
you found a brush yeah i think some
paleontologists forgot their tool
does that look like a piece of bone to
you
horizon formation stegosauruses
they've got stegosauruses
we've got a brush we're still going to
find one now
look at that there's fossils in that it
looks like little clams or something
look at the texture you see in the lake
when it dries up it looks like this see
this was the mud the mud dried up and
then it turned into a rock
we've passed another 12 or 15 signs
pointing out fossil beds but we've kind
of run out of time and need to keep
moving
very seriously guys look there's cowboys
driving cows down the road
all right guys welcome to wyoming
[Applause]
why are you sad
we're here in mountain view wyoming and
we're going to meet becca's folks and
they're going to join us on a little bit
of our sightseeing
you want to see what his bike looks like
yeah
we're going to follow becca's folks over
to fort bridger wyoming
all right this is fort bridger state
historic park
[Music]
nice bison hyde i own two of those this
is fort bridger and apparently it was a
stopover point for the mormon pioneer
trail the oregon trail and the
california trail so lots of people
heading out west would end up swinging
through fort bridger yeah crony express
state i think it's a bear trap yeah
all right so this is the grave of
thornburg the dog which apparently was a
war hero he like warned of indian
attacks stopped a knife fight between
soldiers and saved a drowning boy among
other things it's kind of sad when you
realize that dog has accomplished more
in his life than i have
immediately this is called the
punishment horse if you did something
bad you had to sit on the horse all day
and hold that big wooden sword
oh tommy don't drop it
[Music]
what'd you get the gift shop
a snake and daddy bought himself a
handmade knife you know because they
always need more knives
[Applause]
we just watched jacob trip over his own
feet and it'd just go butt overhead
oh usually that's what nathan does oh
yeah
going on yeah you knocked your own socks
off
[Music]
well listen it is becca's birthday this
week and for her birthday she wants to
go to bear lake and get a raspberry
milkshake
this is a famous bear lake raspberry
shake and it's really good
well babe did you enjoy your milkshake i
did thank you very much thank you for
the detour
all right becca would you like a family
photo for your birthday i would love a
family photo let's do a family photo
well we spent a good 10 minutes yelling
begging and threatening our children to
look at a camera
family photos tearing families apart for
the last hundred years
[Music]
good morning we're in cameron wyoming
and in a few minutes we're gonna get in
the car and head to a fossil quarry all
right guys you ready to go fossil honey
all right guys we're here at american
fossil core in kemmer wyoming and uh
we're gonna be digging fossils fish
fossils turtle fossils stingray fossils
there's all sorts of crazy fossils here
as we can find
and these fish are approximately 52
million years old
so they're out of the eocene period this
one's a stingray poop almost every rock
you split will have some kind of fish
poop in it and that's why all right guys
grab your tools
look at this just
little fish fossils everywhere
oh little fish right there and one of
the fellows will cut that you want you
want to take that one tomorrow
there we go there's one missing its tail
look at that fish scale right there that
is really clear
oh here we go here we go you got that
real careful laying it down
this is pretty awesome isn't it
got a whole one in there i just need to
pick it out really careful all right
guys we've been banging on rocks for
about two hours
and uh we've got a big pile of stuff
right there and uh now we gotta cut
these things up get them all cleaned up
and ready to take home
we're supposed to let these sit and dry
for a couple weeks and then come in with
a little exacto knife you can pick off
the rock that's stuck to the fossil
should look really nice
ah there you go
did you have fun tom yeah i did yeah you
caught you found some really nice
fossils ah thanks you like that jacob
yeah i'll put a link to american fossil
cory's website down in the video
description below
all right guys we've driven 4 800 miles
and we're gonna drive 165 more today so
we're gonna head about three hours north
to jackson wyoming
well jackson's a cute little town but
it's covered in tourists i mean even in
the rain it's just tons and tons of
people on the street but uh it's also
kind of an expensive place to stay
hotels which would normally cost you 150
bucks will cost you three four hundred
dollars all right so we finally found a
place to stay and a place to eat we got
checked in at the lodge here at jackson
hole
and i got a whole bunch of food for
becca's birthday dinner
hey guys
all the benefits of fine dining without
the shame of eating with our kids in
public
fluffy butter with some smoky rosemary
and honey and nuts
oh that's good a little wild boar
sausage and pasta here the mushroom
fettuccine and rack of lamb with mint
pesto i'm going to use my new knife see
it's already coming in handy
it's good it's really good buddy i think
you'll like it
it's my favorite
but we gotta get some kids to bed i will
see you guys in the morning get to bed
stupid
well here we are at another hotel
and getting ready to take off we're
gonna head north from jackson and go see
yellowstone national park and the grand
tetons and
we're gonna try to get all the way up to
montana if we can
we have driven 5 000 miles so far on
this trip and we're going to drive
another 231 today
we're in teton village at jackson hole
ski resort we're going to see if we
can't ride the gondola
[Music]
happy birthday mommy we believe
birthdays are like chinese new year's
they should be celebrated over a whole
week yeah i took my sweat
david's just making himself comfortable
look at the deer see the deer
that's pretty
i like this going up mountains without
having to hike
[Music]
hey guys isn't it fun to think that if
one cable snaps we'll all plunge to our
deaths
do you like wyoming yeah congratulations
wyoming you converted jacob favorite
place to look for both and nathan yeah
i like my book
all right we didn't drive very far we're
here at grand teton national park
well we sprung a little leak all right i
think that's my culprit right there got
a little nail in there look at the air
coming out of that
oh we can make it to bozeman i'll be
able to fix it there
here we are yellowstone national park
no it's hot water but it's boiling
you're giving people access there's two
buffalo right out
there it's pretty cool you got the
steaming hot spring the river and a
bison right beyond it
there's a buffalo walking down the road
went to park and there's a buffalo
walking down the sidewalk
growling at people but it was covered
that looks like concrete
hope nathan's gotten naked again you
look like you're giving yourself a heck
of a wedgie there
oh the water doesn't feel great when it
gets in your eyes it kind of burns like
really salty
that was cool mud volcanoes were awesome
[Music]
that is hot oh that's nice
so we really wanted to check out graham
prismatic springs and this is the one
crazy crowded thing we're gonna do today
it looks really cool from there it looks
like a big rainbow kind of bullseye
becca did you like doing that i did that
was cool
there's a whole bunch of elk out there
tommy there's elk just on the other side
of the luggage
there they are way out there a couple
elk
welcome to montana
that's a lot of beef jerky oh it's
probably different flavors of dirt oh
the beef jerky experience that's neat
well we made it to bozeman montana and
we are hungry so we're gonna go get some
japanese food all right guys we're gonna
try hokkaido ramen house chicken karage
we got gyoza's
all right well it's good to have some
food in us
all right i got the family checked in
and the kids to bed now i gotta go fix
the tire
i got myself a five dollar tire repair
kit
well it wasn't exactly easy but did it
there we go i'm going to bed good
morning it's a beautiful sunday we're
getting ourselves all ready and trying
to get to church on time
i'm going to put the camera down and
i'll see you in a little bit well guys
did you have fun at church yeah
well we ran into some old friends from
virginia and uh they invited us over to
their house rebecca are we ready to
destroy someone else's house let's do it
let's do it
well thank you very much thanks for
stopping by guys all right guys you have
fun with friends yeah
so we're actually at 5
300 miles traveled so far and we're
headed four hours north from bozeman
montana all the way to missoula montana
becca you're eating a leftover corn dog
are you hungry
got spaghetti and meatballs
and uh roast turkey
this is gonna cook up good all right
becca let's give that about 40 miles and
we should have dinner ready
here
oh good morning guys
i did something kind of crazy
i scheduled us to go on a two-day float
fishing camping trip
it starts at six in the morning
we are here in missoula montana with
blackfoot outfitters and we are about to
go on a two-day floating fishing camping
adventure you guys ready yeah
let me introduce you to our guides here
we've got chad and kurt here who have
both bitten off more than they can chew
hop in the truck
how's this for a boat ramp have you guys
ever seen a boat ramp like this
and that's how you launch a boat in
montana the truck are they all gone
spraying it got the pepper spray for the
kids you can't shoot them and they don't
listen so you know
tom you look serious yeah you've been
wanting to learn how to fly fish a lot
haven't you yeah
yeah hold on tight tom
come up one two
because you want your line to straighten
out behind you before you go forward all
right we're gonna get tommy fly fishing
here he's been chomping at the bit to do
this
good perfect man there's mama and
company coming down the river how you
guys doing you guys catch anything we're
like one hour into the trip and becca is
already out fishing me she has two trout
oh there we go that's the fish
beautiful rainbow oh look at that isn't
that gorgeous
all right
my very first montana trout becca's
landing one right now
anything i can do she can do better mom
kind of trout that big
she's so out fishing
you got four i actually
i have zero surprise at all i mean if
you were a rainbow trout who would you
rather be caught by
exactly
caught me that's for sure i have to tell
you i see why people like fly fishing
this is fun
whoa in front
wasn't pretty but i got the second one
becca is tearing him up i'm just
watching her land him over here she's
she's a natural
oh you ready oh there we go
oh i've got a white fish on
oh new species of fish beautiful fish
i'm no becca but that's three fish you
know
becca's got another one
oh i asked her how many fish she had
she's getting uncertain holding up both
hands
oh my first round
i've wanted to catch a brown trout for
years
look at that that is just
gorgeous
oh that's a nice one tom
all right tom keep that rod tough high
over there just like with catfish
there you go there you go that's the
biggest white fish of the day tom
biggest white fish of the boat all right
there he is a little bit
a little muskrat or is that me
well there we go tommy just landed his
first white fish and it was a monster
and shortly after that we had a mink
swim under the boat so we've seen some
bald eagles a marmot meek tommy you hit
the chocolate milk
you've caught two nathan
oh guys you got a big one
it's hard to fish with an earshot of
becca it's it's a little down hardening
becca my fishing queen how are you doing
i landed
on that i missed time to stop for a
little bit of lunch you guys sound good
guys this is quite the spread this is
crazy it's a little hollow though
it's a good sandwich
like watching a suckling pig
nothing like out fishing everyone else
combined to give you an appetite huh
well you look very fashionable in your
grundens why thank you
yeah i told you i didn't need to take a
shower yesterday real good
here tom
you use the reel you can use the reel on
this one look at that that's my reward
for all the good casters i did yeah yeah
i think the 5 am wake time has got to
jacob he's out passed out on your mom's
seat
oh yep he's just passed out right in
there
feeling like a pretty decent fish
it reminds me of a grilling a little bit
mama's got another one what is that is
that trout
oh a nice cut throat
you're not gonna leave me for a better
fisherman are you
pull the rod tip up a little bit there
you go flip it look at it that's a [ __ ]
it's a good fish let him run oh
well you think it's a snag and then the
snag starts going upstream that's a good
fish even though i did catch it i was
like that's totally awesome
oh
sucked it right off the surface
my first cut throat in over 20 years
oh beautiful fish you're getting back in
there
oh on the surface just watch oh
come up and nail it
that is 100 all by yourself
oh there we go oh
and he's off
it's all blanca grande
okay he's going back in he's been out
too long
oh my gosh
look at that tommy well that's number
four
seven tommy's finally figured it out and
he's kicked it into overdrive i'm
catching up on you i'm catching up on
you
i used to do this to my dad thomas said
get another one
get that right
i think chad just saved my life i almost
got killed by cut throat
amazing
thomas
you're rocking me man
you look down the river and see becca on
the other boat at the campsite so i
think we're about to have dinner and i
landed uh 11.
becca how many fish did you catch i
landed 14 i had nine on that i
did not land jacob are you having fun
yeah
well i guess i won't be needing snacks
out do you have snacks
oh
look at this look at this kitchen area
this is legit
you know i just realized that camping's
a whole lot more fun when you walk into
the woods and someone else has set up
everything and is doing all the cooking
he can come back on you huh
that looks really good though
hey becca did you want did you want any
seasoning spice hot sauce i'm good i'm
good you're good of course i always i
always get greedy with my tacos they've
been chewing your mouth closed you like
watching an anaconda eat yeah are you
having a fun time babe i'm having a
great time this is really fun turns out
i like fly fishing
ooh that looks good you like angel food
cake a lot don't you
you're wearing most your whipped cream
okay
well guys it's been a wonderful day but
it's late and time for me and beg to get
to bed so uh we'll check in with you
guys in the morning see you then
[Music]
good morning do you wish mommy would
come on more camping trips
[Applause]
oh this is gorgeous this is this is nice
you get used to this kind of camping
couldn't you it's pretty nice it doesn't
look like it's made right in missoula
are you guys sword fighting
fighting this is really good good
breakfast isn't it oh that was delicious
oh sweet mama's packing lunches
if you're washing dishes then you catch
more fish
to be out fished by mom
oh there we go
oh beautiful back on the head of you
it's the only time today that'll happen
oh nathan's got a fish oh that looks
good oh that's a nice fish bud fish look
at that giant cut throat
there we
go double white fish
all right becca has another massive
trout over there geez that's a nice cut
throat
oh
nice
one oh
thomas nice
oh i got one
there we go
check it out it's white water sherpa
extraordinaire robert
making it look easy robert
you got yourself a truck
dobb's got a brown drought
frown drowned
you know bigger is pretty nice we go on
a fishing trip and we get a white water
rafting trip and a camping trip and
all that stuff all rolled into one
good one
becca you got one too
sweet tell you what becca looks so pro
over there
i've just seen becca like hook four or
five fish in the last five minutes she's
on fire
i'm doing great i'm excited to brag to
my family about what an awesome fly
fisher
i uh married oh
you feel a little better buddy
love you becca thank you for the
sandwich
i'll take it out
oh you're in your hoodie
fun little break a little bit of food is
nice
there you go buddy oh give your give a
rod tip up
[Music]
oh guys that was so much fun but all
good things must come to an end
nathan's out
figured becca caught slightly more than
half of all the fish caught
but yeah we got about 50 fish that's
awesome
that's so much better than i was
expecting guys this was so much fun if
you're ever in montana want to do one of
these camping fishing trips check out
blackfoot river outfitters i'll put a
link down in the video description below
to their information so definitely check
that out this is a really fun trip
come on buddy
we've done 5
800 miles so far and we have
532 miles to go you guys ready to go on
a long drive yeah
all right let's do it
we just saw a sign that said warning
forest fire activity ahead this will be
interesting
this is the firefighter camp
we are seeing a ton of firefighters like
almost every car we pass
we just drove past the national forest
campground and they had it closed off
with a sign that said no entry fire
hazard and all the wooden signs and
information boards were wrapped in tin
foil
welcome to idaho
this road we're on this is the same
trail that lewis and clark took to
discover the path to the pacific ocean
well guys welcome to lewiston idaho
got ourselves a little hotel
well good morning guys our plans are all
up in the air we were supposed to drive
about six hours to mount hood oregon and
go camping with some good friends of
ours they called us up early this
morning and said they've got colds and
are six so
our camping trip in oregon is cancelled
would you guys like to go to rainforest
all right guys we've driven 5 800 miles
so far on our trip and our new plan is
to try to see the pacific coast along
washington state which we weren't going
to get to do so we're going to make
lemons out of this lemonade no we're
gonna make lemonade out of lemons
yeah there's a cruise ship over there
never expected to see a cruise ship in
northern idaho
all right guys welcome to washington
[Applause]
[Music]
we just saw a sign for royal city
washington and becca's like oh my
goodness i have a friend from college
who moved to royal city washington so
she's really quick texting them to see
if they're around and uh i think we
might make a quick diversion becca are
we gonna go see polly here you go see
folly
are you having fun with your friends
yes our children are horrible look
that kid was so well behaved before we
came over say goodbye
[Music]
one two three kids okay we got them all
let's go
they gave us a tupperware full of fresh
blackberries and uh
oh and they're so good
it's 102 degrees outside it's hot out
here in washington
the whole side of the hill is nothing
but tumbleweed
we've probably seen 50 to 70 elk
including some cute baby one
[Music]
well good morning everybody we're just
sitting here enjoying some breakfast and
i'm excited for today because unlike the
last two days
we don't have to cover a whole lot of
ground and we are going to be exploring
the pacific coast and a part of
washington that is absolutely gorgeous
look guys there's a tank what a
wonderful state where you can just drive
down the road and see tanks
look that's the pacific ocean hey guys
there's a beach you want to go to a
beach
air we have made it
all the way from the atlantic to the
pacific
run singles he'll kill you all
do you like this is this cool
yeah
we've made it from one coast to another
from the atlantic to the pacific those
there's only clean pants well
marginally clean no pants playing in a
cold ocean that's my boy
they said your shirt's gonna get full
it's only 70 degrees out now water is so
cold
we just saw a sign for a lighthouse and
my wife loves lighthouses there you go
babe you happy yeah i saw lighthouse
we're in the olympic national park and
this is a temperate rainforest
this is quite the stump isn't it here
babe hi this is the first time we've
ever fit the entire family inside a
stump
wow
there you go world's largest sick of
spruce 58 feet around 191 feet tall and
about a thousand years old and he gets
12 feet of rain every year
all right guys welcome to forks
washington
home of the twilight books what team
edward
all right we got our hotel booked we're
gonna go out and get some food
and nathan
do you guys like to be honest
we got poutine
that
[Music]
got some food in us got a hotel
let's get some rest
stop video taping this well good morning
and welcome to our last full day here in
the lower 48.
we're leaving squim washington and we
have driven 6
480
miles so far
well we finally got our bags all packed
up and we're heading to the airport mom
tommy and nate are gonna head north to
alaska on an airplane and me and jake
are gonna be taking the long route
you guys ready to see grandma and
grandpa though yeah me and jacob are
gonna hang out and have an awesome time
aren't we jake
[Music]
shall we continue north jacob
let's do let's do this
north
to alaska go north to russia
welcome to bellingham international
airport in washington and no we're not
getting on a plane it's time to give up
a rental car we have driven 7 thousand
and five miles in this thing but uh this
is as far as alamo rental car will let
me take it everybody to come hop on it
so we took a taxi from the belly hand
airport here to the bellingham marine
terminal and we're going to be taking
that boat all the way to alaska
now i wanted to drive to alaska but the
canadian border is closed because of
covid
shouldn't have put that fishing rod in
my backpack
no i guess it pushes in
and look at this
this is gonna be our room for the next
five days here aboard the kennecott yes
we got our own bathroom
toilet in our own shower here
so this is the biggest most luxurious
room they have here on the ferry
it fits four people we've got the bunk
beds over here this folds down into a
bed this folds into a bed um most people
don't have bathrooms in there
and their births and some people don't
even have births at all they can camp
out on the deck of the ship are you
going to crawl under there
well i am doing a time lapse of our
entire trip from key west to dead horse
and i'm going to include this as well so
i'm going to get my time lapse set up
and we're going to make sure it's
filming out the window there we go got
our time lapse set up and that thing
will just run the whole trip i brought
my laptop because i am going to be doing
a lot of video editing on this trip this
video is about two terabytes and
somewhere
around fifteen thousand video clips
it'll take me
probably two weeks if i work about 60
hours a week oh looks like we're moving
we're shoving off
all right we just pulled out of the port
of bellingham and we're going past the
san juan islands
one thing that's kind of funny about
this boat is that everything on the boat
runs on alaska time no matter where it
is so when the cafeteria says it opens
at six
it opens at seven o'clock local time but
i'm so sitting on the couch doing some
editing and then it got really quiet
yup
oh those boats will put you to sleep
you hungry you want some dinner and ice
cream
let's go
all right it's getting dark outside
isn't it yeah i'm gonna sleep right up
there
are you warm in there
turn the lights off okay
good morning jacob
what do you want to eat for breakfast
all right buddy here we go
hey look at this
they've got a play area you like that
fishing rod don't you
look i bet you'll see some sea otters
hold on to the rail the boat's moving a
little bit this is turning out to be
such a relaxing day and i needed this so
badly you're a robot yeah
i think there might be some killer
whales out
here oh see there it is
right there see the black way way out
there oh this is the perfect end to a
perfect day sitting on a bed cuddle up
watching godzilla movies kind of excited
because tomorrow morning we're going to
pull into the port of ketchikan alaska
um and so we're going to hopefully get
to see that in the morning but until
then good night i'll see you guys in the
morning
[Music]
you want to get out of your sleeping bag
and go to breakfast
ah
come here
welcome to captain jake
you ready to go explore catch again
welcome to catch can jacob
just hopped in a taxi and we're gonna go
see catch can we only got about two and
a half hours before the boat leaves so
uh we're doing the whirlwind tour
all right guys we're at totem bite park
in catch ken alaska and uh we're gonna
see some real totem poles now fun fact
about me when i was a teenager i used to
carve totem poles and sell them and
stuff like that so i nerd out on this
stuff i love southeast alaska and
british columbian native of carvings now
ketchken's nestled in tongass national
forest it's the largest rain forest in
north america it rains almost 280 days
out of the year here
it's a clan house
oh the cedar smells so good
i actually came here when i was a
teenager with my dad so it's been like
25 years but uh i remember coming here
when i was young man i seriously
considered becoming a professional wood
carver and then i'm really glad i didn't
life turned out pretty darn well
hop on in jake
got a little pot of pinks right there
oh no
it's my first salmon i've seen this year
well thank you very much thank you
we only have about two and a half hours
on shore and uh one of us pooped their
pants
so uh we're gonna head back to the room
a little bit
well we just left catch ken and jacob's
watching some godzilla movies on my
phone and i'm getting some editing done
next stop juno alaska
well i've spent most of the day editing
videos and so we're going to take a
little break and give you guys a tour of
the ship here bottom level is the
vehicle storage that's where everyone's
rvs and cars are this is the cabin level
where we're at here's the dining room
the lounge the theater so a lot of the
cabins don't have their own restroom so
they've got restrooms over here so
people who don't have their own can you
know use the bathroom
so this is the cafeteria they got
breakfast lunch and dinner served here
during specific hours and it's actually
not a bad menu jacob loves the dining
tables because they all the different
animals on them
the movie theater
they show documentaries in here every
few hours throughout the day
so this is the lounge area on the front
of the ship uh when the weather's good
it's a nice place to watch the scenery
and uh just read a book and if you don't
have a three-year-old it can be a nice
quiet place they got a bunch of board
games and puzzles over there you can
borrow as well
let's go up the stairs
so when the weather's good people go and
camp out here on the on the ship
you'd see all the duct tape marks it's
where they tape their tents down but
it's windy and raining today so nobody's
camped out here right now
this is one of the sun decks when the
weather's nasty is one of the better
places to pitch your tent if you're not
going to get a berth
see here if you're trying to take the
ferry on a budget you know camping out
here it'll save you quite a bit of money
rather than renting a berth
almost every level of the ship has a
walkway all around the ship so there's
plenty of places to get fresh air and
just kind of stroll
all right this is the aft observation
lounge where you can sit and watch the
water stroll by
there you go guys this is the front of
the ship and this concludes our tour of
the kennecon
now we're going inside
can i get a set of brussels
a whale goes by kids are going bonkers
well jacob and i got to play with
friends we got to see whales i got a lot
of editing done it's been a nice low-key
day
but it's uh jake's bedtime so we will
see you guys in the morning well it's 6
30 in the morning and we should be
pulling into juno in about 30 minutes
ah
time to wrestle little boys out of their
sleeping bag
all right guys welcome to juno the
capital of alaska it's a small little
town
and uh you can only reach it by boat or
airplane well this is my first time
spending any real time in juneau i've
been to the airport a few times
i got this taxi for an hour and it's a
great way to see the city if you're in a
hurry there you go state capitol right
there
we were driving through the downtown and
just like catch can a lot of little
tourist shops are closed
there's only about two and a half
thousand people that live in downtown
juneau but when a ship comes in it's
like 20 000 people come in here so the
cruise ships are a big deal to a lot of
these small businesses and they haven't
been coming into port for the last year
and a half
we got a whole bunch of sea lions
sitting on on that bar out there hey
jake you wanna go see the salmon real
quick we're here at the salmon hatchery
just outside of town and they've got
a salmon window look at all those chum
salmon
there's some pinks down in there okay
come up here we'll show you where they
jump
the water's just turning with salmon
down there waiting their turn to get up
into the ladder
hey
once the salmon get up in here then the
hatchery workers milk the salmon harvest
the eggs mix it all up
raise the fry and then release them
yeah a little black bear sitting in the
marsh right off the road do a big jump i
got you
all right we've started the engines and
leaving juno next stop yak attack when
we get back to editing videos i have
about three terabytes of unedited video
footage to take care of
and if you are prone to seasickness now
is the time to take your medicine we'll
be out to see in about five hours well
the captain just alerted us we have some
stormy seas ahead in about five hours
we're gonna hit nine to 15 foot waves
and 30 mile per hour wind it's gonna
start rocking and rolling around here uh
me and jacob were just hanging out in
the playroom while i do some editing and
we get a lookout for whales we've got a
code whale code whale
see right there oh is he right there see
right there
he's right over there see him
[Music]
little jacob's zonked out
and the captain's not wrong about the
weather
look at that well i'm curious to see
what happens the waves are supposed to
get worse before they get better
the ship's rocking and rolling and we
figure we go exploring
this is a little bit of a new experience
for jacob man i'm gonna see if he gets
his sea legs or not all right we figured
out how to beat the line at the
cafeteria go in the ships rolling
all right jake how you doing bud
let me let me take a look at your lips
yeah let's get some juice in here
nice potatoes
i took jacob up to dinner and he didn't
need anything and he said he wasn't
feeling well so
i took him out for some fresh air and
now we're just cuddling up and watching
some cartoons
well things are rocking and rolling
pretty good but i kind of need to take a
shower and i've never showered in a
moving ship before so i figured now is a
good time to try it
well good morning
waking up and we're just turning on the
engines to leave yakutat bay we pulled
in at like 5 a.m
i was thinking about getting up to go
visit yakitat but i got jacob up so
early yesterday for juno and he was just
off all day so
i figured we'd just get our sleep got a
little rough last night i was in my bunk
bed and it would kind of slide like this
and then the ship would go and i'd slide
in my bed like this it was it was a
little crazy we've got to go back out
into the gulf of alaska a little bit
today so we'll see how it is we're going
to try to get breakfast before it gets
too rocky
well me and jake have been on this boat
since saturday and it was the perfect
amount of time we got a lot of work done
and got to spend some time together and
have fun but i think we're all ready to
go and i'm really ready to see becca
tomorrow morning did you like the
playroom jacob
well let's get your teeth brushed and
get you changed and ready for bed okay
all right jacob get to bed we're getting
up really early to see mama and grandpa
okay
we're pulling into the port of whittier
and i've got to get my bags and this
little guy off the boat as quickly as
possible my dad's going to meet us
at the dock and we got to get loaded up
and out of whittier quickly because
there's only one way in and out of
whittier and it's through about a mile
and a half long tunnel you can only go
out of the tunnel during certain times
and outbound traffic goes at the top of
the hour until about 6 20. so we've got
we've got to make the outbound tunnel
otherwise we'll get stuck in whittier
for an hour
nothing says alaska more than towing
your uh airplane on a ferry with a
pickup truck
good job jacob you're keeping up
we made it to whittier thanks for coming
picking us up 6 15 is when they close it
off i think so i'm not sure we're going
to make it let's touch and go we're
going to see if we can make the tunnel
out of whittier
well here we go we're following an
airplane through a tunnel when do we get
to do that and we're doing it through
the second longest tunnel in north
america but it's a one-way tunnel
you share it with both directions of
traffic and with railroad tracks so
we're driving on the railroad tracks
right now
[Applause]
[Applause]
my
missed
wife
i missed you
tommy
now we're heading off to the airport to
go pick up our another rental car
so i'm here at alaska 4x4 rental at the
airport and i'm getting my car to head
up to dead horse so you can't take a
normal rental car up on the dalton and
you really really shouldn't do that so
we get a little jeep we're going to rent
and take that up you don't want to mess
around with this so i'm also got a cb
radio and a satellite phone that i
rented as well
i paid extra to have a full-size spare
in addition to the donut
you better believe that's worth every
penny
i'm actually from alaska originally and
we visit frequently to visit family and
film videos so we've actually done six
different travel videos here in alaska
with lots of fun adventures including
survival camping and fishing trips if
you guys want to see those videos check
out our alaska travel video playlist
well good morning we spent yesterday
messing around with family and just
having a good time relaxing and today we
are up and at it because we are packing
the car and headed north
we have driven seven thousand and ten
miles from key west to bellingham
washington then we did
1450 miles on the ferry we did another
50 miles to get to anchorage so right
now we're at about eight thousand five
hundred and ten miles give or take we're
gonna head north through palmer and glen
allen we're doing about 303 miles today
you guys ready yay
do you guys know where your kindles are
at no
well we got a long drive today so we're
gonna make a little stop at a reindeer
farm here in palmer
all right they got dasher dogs that
seems appropriate oh yes excellent
[Music]
don't let her [ __ ] you off
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh he's so soft
that one was chasing me
you guys have fun yeah
used to take me here all the time to get
big burgers you like your food
yep
hey mom the kids are kind of sleepy do
you have any snacks
oh my goodness
hey guys see that pipe in the hill
that's the alaska pipeline
all right guys here we are at the lodge
at black rapids uh just a little south
of delta junction well it's a little bit
late it's the kids bedtime but we got
here just in time to enjoy a little bit
of food before to bed come here jake
this is pretty
and here's our room that's the last in
front here we can have a moose in our
backyard all right time to get the boys
ready for bed
well good morning we got to sleep late
last night and ended up sleeping in
but uh getting the kids dressed we're
gonna grab some breakfast in the lodge
upstairs before heading on up north to
fairbanks
oh thank you
welcome to north pole alaska you want to
see santa's workshop
you guys see reindeer
oh my goodness
[Music]
what did you get it's a survival knife
with me that can transform that's just
my name on it
yeah look at this caribou
well we've driven
850 miles so far we're gonna drive just
a few more go up to fairbanks and uh
we're gonna see what there is to see
there and we're gonna visit a friend
from college
all right we're meeting our friend at
pioneer parks here in fairbanks it'll be
a fun little place for the kids to play
around a little bit
wow there we go gosh i'm so excited
so in about a week and a half it's going
to be me and becca's 20th wedding
anniversary and when we were engaged i
was working on the dalton highway
and heidi was here and so it was like 20
years ago to the day we were like
hanging out in fairbanks or something
all right so this is pioneer park and
you can see like these little shops and
they got a the old paddle wheel boat
that used to be on the tanana trees down
there they're already changing
i know boys we have to go together yeah
they have to get the wiggles out
hey jacob you're way up there aren't you
we got to go
so there's about 700 000 people in
alaska half of them live in anchorage
and the second biggest city is fairbanks
with about 50 000 people
all right we're taking our friends out
to dinner here we're doing some japanese
food
and
[Music]
[Music]
oh then place is awesome
i thought you would like it
what happened it wasn't two minute
bathroom i found something out my mouth
and it's my two
what you
yep
oh my goodness i love it too okay we'll
see you guys at church tomorrow okay
good morning
get up and adam guys you ready for
breakfast let's do it
well today is sunday so we're getting
the kids ready for church and the
timing's working out just perfect
because the only church in between us
and the arctic ocean is here in
fairbanks
well we just finished up church and
we're sitting here in the parking lot
eating cold leftover japanese food
but in here in a little bit we're gonna
head north of the dalton highway 255
miles to cold foot and the dalton
highway is super remote even by alaskan
standards it's a two-lane dirt road that
connects fairbanks to prude bay
and it's really just a supply road so
we've got
food and supplies and emergency
equipment and uh hopefully we won't have
to use it
all right guys time to say goodbye to
pavement it's dirt road time
[Music]
we are the best dressed group on the
entire dalton highway look at us man we
are keeping it classy
when it's dry this road is dusty and
when it's rainy it's muddy and there's
only a little bit of sweet spot in
between look at all this mud
i can't see him
okay
a little baby black bear just ran off
into the woods
i just seen my second black bear of this
trip
see
pick it up guys it's the yukon river
yeah biggest river in
alaska the deck of this bridge is made
out of wood
becca's gonna go touch the yukon let's
go touch the yukon
nice
that's a bit chilly two three
cars properly dirty
the kids are properly climbing the walls
20 years ago i used to come down from
our man camp where i live
down to here and the cook used to put
his phone out on the front porch and i'd
call becca
the dalton is a supply road for pluto
bay so about half the traffic is 18
wheelers hauling goods to and from the
oil field the dalton highway is also the
service road for the great alaska
pipeline and so you drive parallel to it
the entire way to prudent bay and you
can see it quite frequently from the
road
there's an 18-wheeler with a big
bulldozer just parked at the bottom of
the hill over there he's waiting for
another 18-wheeler with a lighter load
to come along and help push him up the
hill
you having fun we're having a great time
it's beautiful it's fun it's fun my
friends with us for a little bit it's
fun
guys check it out we're at the arctic
circle 66 degrees in 33 minutes
we're up on the top of the earth hey
nathan do you know why the arctic circle
is important what it is the point on the
earth at which at the solstice the sun
doesn't set one two three
all right
the clouds have started to urinate on us
we're getting inside
we shall we continue north
all right guys welcome to cold foot the
city with the most extreme temperature
swings in the united states one year
they went from i believe it was 93 to
negative 82 all in the same year if you
like being hot and frozen this is the
place for you
i guess i'll see you later guys i'm
gonna go wrestle these guys into bed
it's the middle of august and uh it's
supposed to get down to 31 degrees
tomorrow night
winter is coming quick we got a
legitimate chance of seeing a little bit
of snow up in atagan pass tomorrow
come on in bud
guys what do you think have you ever
stayed in a hotel like this this is an
alaska bush motel see look they got
shiplap
and plywood well guys it is late and we
gotta get these kids to bed so i'm gonna
put the camera we gotta get up really
early tomorrow
oh
last night was interesting
uh there's no heat in this building and
it's it's pretty cold so that was uh
that was interesting
and there was a mouse under our bed last
night good morning becca
did you have any mice in your room uh
not that i know i only had one
and anthony hungry
well it's about 200 miles before our
next service stop so we're gonna get
some gas here
and uh let's run about 550 a gallon
that's actually not as bad as i was
expecting
i have jacob's milk thermometer says
it's 43 degrees outside typical balmy
august weather
next services are 240 miles away
guess how far dead horse is
240 miles away in alaska you'll notice
that people never use the route number
for the highways they always call it by
its name so it's not route 1 it's the
seward highway it's not route 2 it's the
glen highway it's not route 11 it's the
dalton and in the case of the parks
highway and the dalton highway and some
of the others they're named after the
engineers who designed the road
it's been almost 20 years since the last
time i was on the dalton i've noticed
two big changes one there's a lot more
sections of the road that are paved and
the road's in a lot better shape than it
was 20 years ago and the other is
there's a lot more trees a lot of areas
that i remember being just completely
tundra have you know
birches and willows and stuff in them
look there's a moose right there
there's a moose over by the alaska
pipeline just chilling eating some
seaweed in the bottom of the pond
well he pulled over on the side of the
road for a brief explosive diarrhea
break
and uh we found blueberries
but they're all over here just covered
in blueberries so this stuff i'm
standing on is tundra it's also called
musk egg and it's swampy nasty stuff to
walk in
there's all this water and mud and then
these rolling
knobs that you turn your heel on anybody
who goes hiking across the tundra better
have good ankles there's the blueberries
for you
tommy's outside
oh i'm sorry did we forget somebody hop
in the car
all bud guys we're beginning to climb
into atigan's pass to cross the brooks
range
from here on we're gonna see very little
trees we got a better chance of seeing
caribou we could even see muskox and
eventually maybe even a polar bear
we've got snow
[Music]
oh my goodness guys this is a real store
still sir oh i'm gonna get wet it's too
cold to get wet all right back into the
car back in the car
wow that's slick
that you guys have played on a beach
swam in a river
and been snowed on all in the same trip
just saw an suv that rolled off the road
into the tundra instead of recovering it
someone just wrote for sale on it with
their phone number
that's such an alaskan thing to do
[Music]
time
all right guys welcome to dead horse yay
we're at what 9
500 miles give or take
hey guys check out these oil wells these
a little different than the ones we saw
in oklahoma aren't they
see over there the parking spots with
the electrical plugs they have the
electrical plug so you can plug your car
in in the winter time and it won't
freeze solid you have your oil pan
heater going while you're inside
[Music]
see
these are plugged so you can plug your
car in oh there's a herd of caribou
right there across the river that's
awesome a dead horse ain't a big place
so the one thing we're gonna do is get a
souvenir shirt at the general store
this says dead horse on it
now we made it to dead horse alaska
which is the furthest north the public
can go but it's not the furthest north
you can drive there's actually a good oh
15 20 more miles to get to the arctic
ocean but you have to go through the
secure oil fields of fruit bay to do
that and we
are going to do that
but first we're going to get check in to
our hotel here yes
don't let the door slam
all right let's check this out
all right
yeah this'll work but they got heat and
no exposed plywood check it out we even
have five millimeter plastic blackout
curtains sun doesn't set until 11 pm
tonight so it's nice to have those okay
we haven't been in town very long and we
already get the vibe that there's a
serious bear problem because all the
doors have special bear proof handles
and they told us not to leave any food
in their cars because the bears will
vandalize their cars so
i am going to go and start hauling stuff
out of the car
so kind of fun fact when we checked in
we didn't get any room keys they don't
lock any of the doors or issue any room
keys it's all kind of honor system up
here
i bought it
how far is it to the arctic ocean uh
about 10 10 12 miles
guys we're here
we have been driving for a month and a
half and we are finally here it's way
shorter than i thought it would be dog
you ready to touch the arctic ocean
oh that is cold
that's nippy people
do you want to touch it
jacob was it cold
you touching me i did it was
this is crazy
oh look at this
that is so cool
more of those creepy little bug things
hey hey becca
it ain't fancy
it ain't fancy you found shells i love
it these are arctic ocean shells mama
are you glad you came i'm very glad i
came this is uh it's been crazy a month
and a half hasn't it pretty crazy once
and a half that's an adversary
all right
that spit right there is the farthest
north we can go we're gonna go there
now fruto bay is not the furthest north
you can go in america you can actually
go up to barrow and that will be the
furthest north
but you can't drive to barrow so this is
the furthest north you can get
by driving yay and you did it and it's
the longest road trip in the united
states unless you're gonna go do little
circles or zigzags if you're gonna go in
a straight line longest road trip in the
u.s is key west to prudo bay
and we did it
yay
now we gotta head back
oh
now we didn't go in a perfectly straight
line but according to my gps and
odometer we did slightly over
9500 miles
since july 7th and today is august 16th
so we did about 9 thousand miles in a
month and a half
we can't start school on monday yeah
kids start school on monday we gotta
really make tracks and to do that we've
gotta drive
987 miles back to acreage and then catch
a flight and then we'll fly 10 hours to
virginia we will have driven uh about 10
500 miles on this road trip
there you go tom let me get your picture
you are now at the furthest north you
can drive
you guys have traveled
almost 10 000 miles is that pretty cool
yeah now we're sword fighting
hey jacob should we go back to virginia
yeah i'll race you there go
you guys have fun though
yeah
chicken yeah mom you like the food it's
very good
has this been a pretty crazy adventure
yeah
all right guys i'm gonna fish from the
sag river
it's a beautiful beautiful arctic
grayling
i would have been sad if i hadn't caught
at least one arctic railing on this trip
can't tell you how it makes my heart
feel to just be in a beautiful place
like this and catching these fish but
it's uh time to go to bed
that right there is what a grizzly bear
print looks like
there's his claws way out there in front
there's his front paw there's his back
paw
oh it's pushing midnight it's almost
dark outside
so i better get going to bed i'll see
you guys in the morning we got a lot of
driving to do all right guys we're
leaving dead horse and heading 1 000
miles south to anchorage
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys we did it we drove from
prudow bay to anchorage in one day 18
hours in the car
we got to get some kids to bed we'll
talk about this in the morning well
there you go that's it we've completed
the longest road trip in the united
states 10
410 miles but i hope you guys enjoyed
this video we got lots of travel videos
in our travel video playlist and
definitely check it out i'll put links
down in the video description below and
a lot of the fun activities we did i'll
have links to those as well in the video
description i'll tell you what though
i'm exhausted and i desperately need a
shave and a haircut so i'm gonna put
this up and i will see you guys next
saturday morning so don't forget to
click subscribe if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this and
don't forget to click subscribe so you
can see other great videos every
saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications thanks
for watching
[Music]